hurricane durian one of the strongest
storms ever formed in the Atlantic is
creeping toward the southeast coast
durian is still a category 5 storm
causing devastation in the northern
Bahamas it's forecast to start turning
north by tomorrow morning but we still
don't know for certain where it will go
take a look at this incredible video
taken inside the eye of the storm
meteorologist Megan Glaros so far
Chicago Station wbbm-tv is here Megan
what's latest we are indeed looking at
still a very powerful monster of a storm
that has moved essentially not at all in
the last hour it's moving at only 1 mile
per hour you can see category 5 status
right now winds to 165 miles per hour
again movement at 1:00 it's a hundred
and 25 miles east of West Palm Beach and
we do anticipate that turn to the north
but it's going to be close enough to the
Florida coastline that as it stands
right now with the National Hurricane
Center track we're anticipating that the
area shaded in yellow here so really for
Pierce areas stretching up to the north
a four to seven foot storm surge is
possible within those zones let's take a
peek get storm surge is only one
elements of flooding potential with
tropical systems we also have the
rainfall that's coming down most intense
around the Bahamas but take a look here
that even areas of Florida getting be
hit hard by rainfall and if it shifts
just 40 miles west look how different
that story will be that's why we're
watching this so very carefully because
again that turn to the north needs to
happen it's a critical time right now
Tony